uh first i mean first of all i want to
say that you look like an
angel who went to heaven i don't mean
that in a nice way but the background is
really blurry is that intentional
oh it's just on the skype it we edit
everything in post i'm edited out in
post and they put in an attractive
uh black woman to do the show so they
can you give me like
bigger boobs yes we're gonna make them
really huge i want
them i want them like on the resting on
the table we're gonna give you a huge
tip i'm gonna take you out of a cell and
we're gonna put a cigarette back in your
mouth how dare you
quit how dare you i have to
i have to i had to stop smoking cooking
and drinking
okay what do you mean define have to
um i have a i have i should probably
just come
i have um a sexually transmitted
infection called i'm like eight months
pregnant
so is that true yeah well
congratulations
i mean do people know that with with the
next big uh neoliberal novel no they
don't but i'm gonna just come clean
because everybody's always speculating
oh my god so you're coming clean on the
tim dillon show and saying that you are
pregnant
yeah like a typical woman i have to drum
up some um
suspense and like emotionally extort
people into you know i'm gonna play the
victim for the next six weeks
right my back hurts this is
unacceptable i really wanna i wanna call
you know i wanna say i want to walk
around
saying this is unacceptable how do you
plan to hold them accountable you know
rectify all that
i have like six weeks left is your do
you have a name picked out for the baby
um no not yet i'm to call it
neoliberalism
or something stupid i don't know i
haven't thought about it i think
i i think it's like really a bad idea to
think you know the people are like very
precious about this kind of [ __ ] and
they like
think about it and they give it some
like weird like gay edwardian name and
just like i don't know kids should be
like
seen and not heard they should recede
into the background be saddled with like
you know adult chores i'm only doing
this so i can have like an
unpaid domestic server you know because
i don't want to pay
i need somebody to produce my podcast i
think
the name my parents gave me they gave me
the name timmy because they go
let's give him a a name where
if he is uh a fat [ __ ] it will fit
so perfectly that it'll because timmy is
the name that was
the the name of the [ __ ] growing up it
was the name of the guy that was always
joked around about like
timmy so they gave me that uh which i i
truly appreciate had my name been like
justin i would have had a different life
well you would have been like the class
rapist
that's true and not a homosexual
comedian that's a very good
it's a good name it's like very generic
but um cute i love tim's my best
friend's name
that's nice okay you're my new best
friend